les activités sportives en fait l'UNSS
des zivelin a proposé ce mercredi 14
septembre des animations physiques et
sportive dans le cadre de la Journée
nationale du sport scolaire pour ce
rendez-vous le directeur académique des
Yvelines Serge Clément est venu au lycée
des métiers Louis Blerot de trappe
objectif promouvoir les associations
sportives des collèges et lycées on a
grâce à cette manifestation un petit peu
phare en début d'année scolaire la
possibilité de rencontrer des élèves
d'aller à la rencontre des élèves de de
montrer ce que ce dont on est capable ce
que l'on est capable d'offrir dans les
établissements et surtout de de
provoquer une adhésion non seulement à
l'activité physique et sportive mais
aussi à des associations sportives les
associations sportives des
établissements scolaires permettent aux
élèves de pratiquer et découvrir le
sport en compétition et parfois de créer
des vocation il y a une bonne ambiance
le prof apprend super bien en fait aux
élèves et ça me permet just d'apprendre
des des sports de combat pour le métier
de plus tard je vais m'inscrire en club
ben grâce à l'UNSS parce que ben j'ai
mon niveau il est assez évolué quoi pour
l'année scolaire 2015-216 près de 24000
élèves se sont inscrits à une
association sportive dans leur
établissement certains jeunes hilinois
ont réalisé des performances on a le
tennis par exemple tous les ans ù qui se
qualifi qui sont champion de France et
qui vont même au championnat du monde
scolaire si les sports collectifs
connaissent chaque année le même succès
les activités en pleine nature comme le
raid se développent les sports comme la
boxe l'athlétisme ou le judo vont
pouvoir compter cette année sur lesffit
Jeux olympiques de Rio afin d'attirer de
nouveaux
pratiquants